foreign
Irish mythology is filled with entities
that are both fascinating and terrifying
here are 12 of the deadliest Irish
mythical monsters and creatures let's
get to it the first one the Banshee this
is a female Spirit from the Irish
folklore that is said to appear as an
old hag or sometimes as a beautiful
young woman the Banshee is typically
associated with death and is set to wail
and scream loudly for telling the death
of a family member according to Legend
the Banshee is only heard by certain
families usually those with Irish
ancestry or those who have been visited
by the spirit in the past her railing is
said to be heard at night either outside
the family home or inside of it number
two Balor Balor also known as Baylor of
the evil eye is a giant from Irish
mythology who is known for his fearsome
appearance and destructive power he is
said to have been the king of the
fomorians a race of giants who were
known for their strength and battle
prowess he is depicted as having only
one eye which is said to be very
powerful that it could cause destruction
with a single glance he is also depicted
as having an imposing stature and is
said to be able to crush his enemies
with ease
number 3 the dullahan often depicted as
a headless horseman who carries his own
head which is said to Glow with an eerie
light according to Legend the dullahan
rides through the countryside at night
carrying its head in one hand and a Whip
made of human spine on the other it is
said to call out the name of the person
who is about to die and when it stops
riding that person's life is said to be
over it is said that it cannot be
stopped or deterred and that the doors
and Gates will open for it as it passes
number four the overtak this was a
malevolent dwarf ruler who terrorizes
subjects using his dark powers to
enslave them and force them to do his
bidding as well as feed on their warm
blood avatak was buried in a shallow
grave but it is said to have risen from
the dead three times only to be killed
again and again only after a druid
instructed the chieftain to impale the
monster with a stake through its heart
was it finally defeated this creature
was also the real inspiration to Brands
tokus Dracula number five the Dover coup
according to Legend the doverku is a
Fierce and aggressive creature that
lives in rivers and lakes in Ireland it
is said to have a sleek black coat and
webbed feet and was also called the
otter King the dovaku is said to be
aggressive towards humans and there are
many stories of it attacking and killing
people who Venture close to his
territory it is said to be able to emit
a piercing almost human-like scream
which it uses to intimidate its prey and
also warn off potential threats
this is a pagan deity who was worshiped
by the ancient Irish according to Legend
Grand cruik was a dark and malevolent
God who demanded human sacrifice for his
worship
he was said to be large as a black stone
Idol surrounded by 12 smaller Idols each
representing a month of the year in some
accounts he is described as a large
black stone Idol surrounded by these 12
smaller Idols while in others he is said
to have looked like a giant serpent or a
terrifying worm
number seven the Morrigan the Morgan is
a goddess from Irish mythology who is
often associated with death war and fate
she is typically depicted as a powerful
and enigmatic entity who can take on the
form of a crow or a raven the Morrigan
is also sometimes associated with death
and the underworld and is said to be
able to shape-shift into the form of a
banshee or a death Omen in some Legends
She is said to have the power to control
over the fate of individuals and to
bring about their downfall
number 8 the coronak this is a creature
from Irish folklore that is sometimes
referred to as the mother of demons it
is said to have been a powerful and
malevolent creature often described as a
serpent or a dragon-like creature or
either as a gigantic worm according to
Legend the coronak was a terrifying
creature that quickly grew into the
large sea monster that was terrifying
and was eating all the cattle in the
land also known as the worm of log there
it was slain by Saint Patrick after a
heated argument
number nine The Ellen Dragon The Ellen
dragon is a three-headed monster
referred to in Irish mythology as a
demon with three heads the origins of
this Ellen dragon is not well known but
some scholars believe that it may have
been inspired by the traditions of the
banshi which is a spirit associated with
death and Misfortune elsewhere it is
mentioned as having emerged from the
cave of croacan and laid ways to Ireland
until it was killed by the ulate poet
and hero called American
number 10 the bananak in early Irish and
Scottish folklore the bananak were
pre-natural beings described as specters
which haunts battlefields this
terrifying screeching demons that live
in the air may have had the appearance
of goats they were linked to acts of
murder and death they also may have been
related in a way to banshees but differ
in that bunches whale and Horn families
while the bananak are drawn to Wars and
battles especially after a bloodshed
number 11 The Mucky Mucky is the name
given in Irish folklore to a mysterious
creature set to inhabit the lakes of
Kalani in Ireland scientists once
perform a series of sonar scans in 2003
to determine local fish populations
there however a large solid object in
the water was recorded which has led to
the theory that the lake might be
inhabited by some form of lake monster
similar to the famed Nessie of Loch Ness
in October 2004 a Japanese TV crew spent
a week there in the region looking for
Mucky but to no avail
and number 12 the slug this is a
creature from Irish mythology that is
also known as the host of The Unforgiven
dead it is often described as a horde of
army of restless spirits who are said to
fly through the air and roam the
countryside causing mischief and Mayhem
wherever they go the slog is often
associated with death and danger and is
said to be particularly active during
the winter months where the veil between
the worlds is tennis so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video on the 12th
Irish monsters do hear the like button
for support and subscribe but most of
all smash that Bell icon for regular
updates and new videos right here on
this channel till the next one take care
fam